researchers around the world are
stitching new functions into textiles
enabling them to harvest energy light up
change colors detect pollution even
communicate one problem is that
intelligent textiles are created by
chemically treating fabrics before
they're made into clothing and those
treatments can wear out rapidly now
researchers have incorporated new
functional molecules into cotton plants
as they grow which allows the plants to
build the new functional fibers they did
this with a sweet idea
modified sugars they started with
hydroponically grown cotton plants that
grow in dishes rather than a field they
fed the plants water spiked with glucose
molecules linked to other functional
molecules which were then absorbed by
the plants and passed to the fiber
forming cells where they were used to
build the plants cotton fibers in one
example the researchers linked
fluorescent molecules to the sugars
after 20 days of growth the fibers
appear yellow under normal light but
when exposed to UV light they glow a
brilliant green the researchers also
linked magnetic compounds to their
sugars and showed that they too were
incorporated into the fibers in the
future that can enable clothing makers
to build data storage capabilities right
into garments this is probably just the
beginning smart clothes promise to give
us stronger lighter and brighter attire
and when grown right into the fibers
those add-ons may never fade or wear out
you
[Music]